welcome back to las vegas now pink jeep
tours has been providing adventures for
the past
60 years and they are now showcasing the
strip from all angles take a look
more than 6 million people have toured
the country in one of these pink jeeps
and this is jerry with pink jeep doors
before we talk about your latest
excursion
give everyone the history of the company
pink jeep started in 1960 in sedona
arizona
expanded here to las vegas in 2001. we
now have
places in tucson just outside the south
rim of the grand canyon
and the great smokies in tennessee your
latest tour is called the land
air and sea tour can you tell me about
it well instead of telling you about it
why don't i just show you it so we
started at the pink jeep headquarters
someone's watching right now you pick
them up
where do you pick them up at we will
pick them up at any of the hotels along
the strip whichever is most convenient
and then from there we'll start our tour
at the world famous welcome to las vegas
sign
welcome to fabulous las vegas this is
stop number one jerry will get you up to
the front you get your picture taken in
front of the sign
and then what is the rest of the tour
involved from here we'll drive up the
strip
we'll talk a little history of the
properties we'll tell you about little
things that used to be in certain places
and we'll take a drive by the fremont
street experience or at least get a
chance to see where the
the canbe is that they do light shows
every night and then you guys now
actually you stop at the link as well if
you
need to ride the high roller yep left
from there we'll stop at the link
you'll get uh a view of the strip from
550 feet high
and then our final stop is going to be a
helicopter tour right our last stop will
be at maverick helicopters and you'll
get a chance to see the strip
from about a thousand feet think of how
many times you've driven down this strip
you're kind of always focused or you can
kind of peer out your window
when do you get a view like this an
open-air jeep beautiful shots of all the
casinos sitting here with your family
and friends
it's a perfect night out here we go the
final part of the tour and this is so
exciting we're going up in a helicopter
this is our pilot matt how long have you
been flying
i've been flying for 12 years i've been
a pilot here at maverick for just over
six
so today we are in an airbus h130 the
model we're in as a b4
as you can see stadium seating leather
seats
full wrap around view of windows and
visibility
it's one thing to see the strip from the
ground but when you're up
where we are about a thousand feet
it's a whole different perspective this
really is
a bucket list type of trip seeing the
las vegas boulevard
with the jeep and the open air toward
ending it in a helicopter
and this is normally done at night so i
only imagine this is gorgeous right now
what it must be like at night would just
see the sparkling lights on the strip
down below
do you have engagements that people
propose on the flight lots of proposals
lots of weddings
um we also get married over on the
helicopter over this trip
so there's actually weddings that take
place on the helicopter where you have
the minister of the free stuff run and
the couple in the back
you have the writing room right in the
front the minister and the photographer
in the back and
you get married while you're doing what
we're doing now all right
there we have it well done well done
this is it's got to be the best tour
the best tour west of the mississippi
i'll go as far as to say that it's
awesome